here tonight is like I know I'm getting
an award I'm a winner here there is no
no nothing no pressure in that way I
don't like the pressure I this is my
first time so I don't understand how
intense it is just getting the
nominations was terrifying what if
because it felt like so many a big part
of the world was wanting it so bad like
I'm bad at public speaking so I kind of
I'm half happy when we lose uh so I
don't have to go up there but uh no it's
it's better to be in the mix than not to
be in the mix so um it's it's really
both exciting and scary at the same time
as much as I'm able to enjoy anything I
have a negative tendency which I have to
really kind of combat but no I'm
seriously yeah it's absolutely marvelous